welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your house definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spider-man and Marvel fans
must feel like they're in a Mysterio
illusion this week with Tom Holland
pretty much being Schrodinger's spider
we don't know if he's in or if he's out
of the MCU but it looks like
negotiations are still ongoing with this
new report that comes directly from
comic book calm Tom Holland appeared at
Keystone comic-con on Sunday to an
audience of 2,000 people and beforehand
attendees were told not to ask any
spider-man questions because it may mess
up contract discussions that are
announced in the next few days this
comes directly from panel attendee PC
Tears who said the following
guys they just told us we can't ask
questions about the whole Sony Marvel
thing so we don't mess up any contract
discussions that will be announced
within the next few days
Holland then went on to do a 45 minute
panel in which he said the following
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
okay so this seems pretty strange as the
audience were told they weren't allowed
to talk about it and yet Holland's on
stage divulging information about
spider-man 3 and so on the Twitter user
was later asked by website The Inquirer
to clarify his statements and she said
the following it was kind of odd to be
told not to ask about it but then had
them ask it in the interview the answer
he gave was so scripted I think they're
still working on it
it was almost literally word-for-word
while he said at d23 this I completely
agree with and the main reason I didn't
cover the keystone comments is because
it was pretty much word-for-word what
was said at d23 and just seemed like a
repeat of the story
however most new stories are reporting
that Holland is 100% out of the MCU
which I actually find quite strange and
do think that no one seems to have
picked up on the key point of this
entire thing at no point during any
interview that I've seen has anyone ever
mentioned the MCU once whilst they have
said that Disney and Sony are no longer
working together and yet that's pretty
much everywhere I completely agree that
they've split they have not actually
stated that the film's will be
disconnected and that there is no way
that spider-man can mention any of the
prior events or discuss the characters
these reports always seemed a little
weird to me as a thing that even if Sony
and Disney did decide to part ways there
isn't really anything to stop spider-man
mentioning Tony Stark all the other
characters some might say that this
would cause legal issues but I highly
doubt it there's a very famous scene
from the original spider-man Sam
we film in which Aunt May mentioned
Superman who is of course owned by DC
and there are umpteen scenes from the
arrow verse that discussed heroes from
the Marvel Universe even though they are
part of DC properties I think even if
Disney and Sony do split that the films
will still remain at least in some ways
able to be connected to the MCU there's
not really anything to stop Sony from
mentioning the characters that feature
in the Marvel Universe and they've even
brought aboard the writers from
homecoming and far from home to work on
spider-man 3 just because Kevin Feige
isn't a producer doesn't mean that it's
not connected to the MCU and as we saw
in the Netflix shows in which he wasn't
really involved his name missing doesn't
mean that things are unconnected I
personally do believe that negotiations
are still ongoing as we've not had an
official statement from Disney or Sony
saying that it's all over the closest
thing that there's been to this was the
interview with Kevin Feige for aw com in
which he said that he knew that they had
spider-man for a finite amount of time
but even then doesn't say it's all over
and negotiations failed he's out of the
MCU if you go back and watch those
interviews from a PR standpoint then
they seem pretty scripted and neither
really mentioned the collapse of
negotiations or what percentages except
over part of the contracts in addition
to this comic book calm have just posted
within the last hour that Tom Holland
says that the Peter and Tony scene in
spider-man homecoming is a pivotal
moment for the two films we've made and
the one we're making which yet
definitely confirms to me that
spider-man will still somehow be
connected to the MCU at the moment I
don't think that anyone can 100% say
that spider-man is fully out the MCU
until we have an official statement from
Disney or Sony and the fact that
Keystone comic-con audience members were
asked not to say anything in case they
mess of contract negotiations definitely
gives this theory a lot more weight I
may be wrong and hey I have been in the
past let's not forget but I'm still of
the thinking that both corporations are
too smart to fully confirm that
spider-man is out the MCU due to the
damage that it will do to both
franchises obviously I'd love to hear
your thoughts on this entire thing do
you agree with me or am I just trapped
in one of Mysterio's illusions refusing
to see the truth comment below and let
me know and if you enjoyed this video
then please give it a thumbs up
make sure you check out my full
breakdown of Tom Holland and Kevin Feige
statements from d23 which should be
linked at the end I'll also leave my
sources in the description if you want
to read up on them as I know in the last
couple of videos people have been asking
for them so yeah they'll all be there if
you want to come talk to me about movies
TV shows games and comic books then you
can follow me on twitter at definition
YT it's the best way to get in touch
with me and it's the perfect place to
suggest new videos and content so
hopefully I see you over there
after this also just want to let you
know that we're giving away a free copy
of John Wood 3 and blu-ray and all you
have to do to be in with a chance of
winning is to like this video make sure
that you subscribe to the channel and
leave your thoughts on the spider-man
news in the comment section below the
winner will be chosen at random on
September the 10th and the blue arrow be
shipped out from then to have a good
surprise
so best of luck to everyone who takes
part this is a channel for people who
are super into superheroes so if that's
the kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]